Jaime Lannister: According to legend, a huntsman
once tracked a lion that was terrorizing its
village all the way to its den.
Though armed with only a spear, the man managed
to kill both the lion and its mate, but spared
the cubs.
This mercy so pleased the Old Gods that they
sent a shaft of sunlight deep into the cave,
gleaming off golden walls.
The hunter became a miner and built a ringfort
to guard his new wealth.
Nobody ever asks what happened to the cubs.
Maybe the gods forgot about them, and they
starved.
Maybe there never were any cubs or lions or
hunter, doesn't matter.
Someone found enough gold in that cave to
buy whatever truth he wanted, along with a
castle that he'd name after his new family.
Casterly Rock.
Thanks to that gold, Casterly Rock soon became
the largest, wealthiest, and best-defended
castle in Westeros.
An army that struggled up the main approach
would still have to climb thick, high, and
well-defended walls.
Should they choose instead to lay siege, the
sea helpfully carved a massive cave beneath
the castle, which over time, became a private
port complete with docks, wharves, and shipyards.
And so to this day, even with all the gold
in Westeros to tempt invaders, Casterly Rock
has never fallen.
At least not in battle.
The castle is sadly all that remains of its
namesake family, the Casterlys.
According to another legend, my ancestor Lann
the Clever, swindled the castle from them.
The most common story is that he found a hidden
cleft in the rock and snuck into the castle.
As night, he whispered threats into sleeping
ears, howled in the darkness, planted one
brother's treasures in the room of another,
and so forth.
By the end of his games, the Casterlys believed
a demon was haunting their home and fled.
My brother prefers a different version.
Lann the Clever did find a secret entrance
into the rock but used it to have his way
with the Casterly maidens.
Eventually, the girls gave birth to golden-haired
bastards, and the Casterlys had no choice
but to accept their father into the family.
In gratitude, he changed the family name to
honor himself, and House Lannister was born.
The Casterlys used the gold of the rock to
become lords.
The Lannisters became kings.
For thousands of years, the Kingdom of the
Rock ruled the Westerlands.
When the ironborn became a nuisance, my ancestor
sailed to the Iron Islands and returned with
a hundred ironborn hostages, promising to
hang one from the rock every time the ironborn
dared raid our shores.
The ironborn stayed away, well, after twenty
or so.
When the Andals arrived after sweeping across
the rest of Westeros, we invited their sons
and daughters into the rock as squires and
court ladies.
I don't think we ever had to hang any of them.
Finally, Aegon the Conqueror defeated us on
the Field of Fire, and my ancestor knelt.
Still, little changed but titles and taxes,
for when Visenya Targaryen saw the rock, she
gave thanks that my ancestor had met Aegon
on the field.
Even dragon flame would have washed over the
castle like the waves and left just as much
a mark.
Jaime Lannister: When disciplining unruly
vassals, most lords send armies.
My father, Tywin, only had to send a singer.
There's no faster way to dull a vassal's ambition
or any festive occasion than hearing The Rains
of Castamere.
House Reyne of Castamere was an old and proud
house that was slowly sinking back into the
muck.
Their mines had run dry.
Without gold, they turned to a more common
source of wealth.
Daughters.
Lady Ellyn Reyne was betrothed to my great
uncle.
But when he fell in battle, Lady Ellyn sought
comfort in his twin brother's bed, beating
out the other woman he had promised to marry.
Then the husband, who had shared his twin's
wife, shared his twin's death on a different
battlefield.
Lady Ellyn flung herself at the new and married
heir to the Rock, but my grandfather Tytos
was more kitten than lion.
He ran away and told his wife of Lady Ellyn's
designs, and Lady Ellyn soon found herself
married off to WalderanTarbeck, lord of another
failing house.
The Reynes and Tarbecks should have sunk into
obscurity together, and they would have if
not for my grandfather becoming Lord of Casterly
Rock.
At first, the Westerlands laughed with the
"Laughing Lion," as the jovial Tytos was called.
But when men realized this lion had neither
teeth nor claws, they started to laugh at
him.
None laughed harder than the Reynes and Tarbecks.
Though Lady Ellyn was no longer welcome at
Casterly Rock, Tytos didn't refuse her brothers
Roger and Reynard Reyne, not even when they
asked for extravagant loans.
Thanks to our family's gold, Lady Ellyn restored
Tarbeck Hall to a splendor she hadn't known
since being cast out of our home.
When my grandfather broached the subject of
repayment, Roger and Reynard only laughed.
And soon enough, my grandfather was laughing
along with them.
Then my father Tywin returned from the War
of the Ninepenny Kings, where he'd seen how
the rest of the realm sniggered at House Lannister.
Determined to restore our proper place, my
father demanded the immediate repayment of
all debts to the Rock or a hostage from those
who couldn't pay.
Reynard Reyne merely laughed when he received
the raven.
Lord WalderanTarbeck chose to ride to Casterly
Rock, sure that he could cow Lord Tytos into
rescinding my father's commands.
He could have, except it wasn't Tytos who
met him at the gates but my father, who had
Lord Walderan thrown into a dungeon.
Lady Ellyn protested.
The Reynes threatened war.
And finally, my grandfather broke and released
Lord Tarbeck with an apology, no less.
As if bathing himself in shame, Tytos further
forgave all the Tarbeck debts to our house.
To celebrate the end of hostilities, Lord
Roger feasted Tytos at Castamere, and the
two lords proclaimed their friendship for
eternity.
My father allowed eternity to last a year.
When he summoned the Reynes and Tarbecks to
Casterly Rock to answer for their crimes,
they rose in revolt, exactly as he expected.
Their defiance gave him a pretext to call
his banners and ride for Tarbeck Hall and
Castamere with an army behind him.
He didn't even bother to inform my grandfather.
My father's army descended on the Tarbecks
so quickly that Lord Walderan had no time
to gather his forces, and rode against my
father with only his household knights.
Soon his head, his sons' heads, and the heads
of any man with Tarbeck blood adorned the
spears of the Lannister vanguard as it marched
to Tarbeck Hall.
At their approach, Lady Ellyn Tarbeck closed
the gates and sent ravens to her brothers
at Castamere.
She assumed they'd have more than enough time
to muster their armies and break what would
be a long siege.
My father had trebuchets up in a day and brought
down the keep within hours.
Lady Ellyn and her son were crushed in its
fall.
When the Tarbeck forces surrendered, my father
put their castle to the torch.
Roger Reyne arrived with his army just in
time to see the flames consuming his sister's
home.
He charged my father's camp, hoping surprise
would win out over my father's great numbers.
It didn't.
With half his men dead on the field and a
cross-bolt in his back, Lord Roger fled back
to Castamere.
The Lannister host arrived at Castamere three
days later.
Like Casterly Rock, the seat of House Reyne
had begun as a mine.
When the gold gave out, the mine shafts were
widened into halls, galleries, and bedchambers
deep beneath the earth.
The Reyne brothers didn't have the men to
defend the castle walls and retreated into
their underground stronghold.
From this relative safety, they offered terms
to my father to avoid a long siege.
My father didn't reply.
Instead, he commanded that the mines be sealed
with stone and soil until there was no way
in and no way out.
When that was completed, it took less than
a day to dam the stream beside the castle
and only two to divert it to the nearest mine
entrance.
The Reynes had taken more than three hundred
men, women, and children into the mines.
A few guards reported hearing faint screams
and shouts below them one night.
But come dawn, the earth was silent once again.
And now the rain weeps o'er their halls, with
no one left to hear.
Tywin Lannister: On the far western coast
of the continent, high atop a rocky promontory
overlooking the Sunset Sea, sits Casterly
Rock, ancestral seat of House Lannister.
Below it lies Lannisport, one of the great
cities of Westeros.
A center of trade, culture, and the great
Lannister fleet.
There are a number of gold and silver mines
in the Westerlands, making it the richest
region in all of Westeros.
One of our most productive gold mines lies
beneath Casterly Rock itself, making House
Lannister the wealthiest of all the noble
houses.
This allows House Lannister to fund many endeavors
of other noble houses.
Even the king himself has sought credit from
Casterly Rock from time to time.
We Lannisters claim our descent from the Andal
invaders and, through the female bloodline,
Lann the Clever.
According to the legend, Lann, using only
his wits, won Casterly Rock from the noble
house of Casterly during the Age of Heroes.
The Lannisters reigned as Kings of the Rock
for thousands of years and worked to make
it the envy of the rest of the Seven Kingdoms.
Our time as kings ended, however, when Aegon
Targaryen, otherwise known as Aegon the Conqueror,
arrived in Westeros with his army.
The last King of the Rock, King Loren Lannister,
joined forces with King Mern Gardener, the
King of the Reach.
Together, with sixty thousand men, they met
the Targaryen host in open battle.
History tells us that Aegon unleashed all
three of his dragons, slaughtering four thousand
men at what came to be known as "the Field
of Fire."
King Mern himself was burned alive that day,
and House Gardener turned to ash with him.
Seeing both the threat and opportunity the
Targaryens represented, Loren wisely surrendered
and aided Aegon in his further conquest of
Westeros.
The Lannisters were thus appointed Lords Paramount
of the Westerlands and Wardens of the West,
titles we hold to this day.
Let us be clear.
It is neither luck nor royal favor that makes
our House prosperous.
There have been times in our history when
some have considered thought us weak, lazy,
or opulent.
My father, Tytos Lannister, nearly bankrupted
our House with his poor investments and allowed
himself to be mocked openly at court.
When our vassal, the Reynes of Castamere,
dared to rise against the Lannisters, they
learned how dangerous it can be to taunt a
lion.
I, Tywin Lannister, personally led the assault
on Castamere to put down this rebellion.
I made an example of them, to anyone who doubts
our might.
They even made a quaint song about the fate
of the Reynes of Castamere.
But sadly, there are no Reynes left to hear
it.
Today the golden Lion of Lannister is rightly
admired and feared throughout the Seven Kingdoms.
Our words are "Hear me Roar," but there are
of other words that should be remembered when
crossing a lion of Casterly Rock.
"A Lannister always pays his debts."